[Applaudissements]
je me battais mais qu'est ce que c'est
la meilleure amie voilà je dois quand
même voter venue voilà j'ai embrassé
était avec vous en tunisie il est
toujours avec moi c'est mon frère on
était je te voyais là l'écrou commence à
l'ua mais souvent sans appel je suis
exposé sur la banque net de ma mère
parce qu'il a dit une phrase parce que
moi je raconte tout il compte faire son
troisième film je vous le dis il sera
sur moi non je peux leur dire de ton
film je fais un tour le troisième film
il s'appelle ça sera sur la vie de cyril
s'appelle la revanche du moche ça mais
on sait moss qui se vengera qui vert
pour la vente verbaux il a la classe et
de fous rires j'étais donc un biopic sur
série la nuit les vidéos que viviane g
d'accord dans le titre franchement
j'adore le type n'est d'accord et j'ai
en même temps je suis né là bas et que
si oui j'aimerais quand même peut-être
que comme celle des meilleurs amis si ce
n'est son meilleur ami
on a peut-être quand même quelques
dossiers à bâle ont suffisamment
et raconte un dossier tout ça j'ai un
dossier c'est mort chez sa maman on a
mangé un petit couscous et sa maman et
j'ai je comprenais pas pourquoi cyril
été autant rapide autant speed
je me suis dit qu'est ce qu'il a il ya
pas eu un problème petit et sa mère je
peux leur dire sa mère m'a dit avery
terme a dit écoute cyril depuis l'âge de
la marche et à l'âge de deux ans ah bon
ouais le pire le pire c'est qu'il a
parlé à l'âge de deux ans mais non
c'était ça comme sur l'a10 à la 52e et
regarder les gens
c'est ça ton film parce que alors est ce
qu'on va faire une interview sérieuse
l'a fait lors de coin va parler ton film
bon s'est expliqué ce n'est pas dit je
vais même pas raconté ils doivent bien
d'ailleurs voir le film la première
partie va parler essentiellement
d'éducation nationale c'est important
il a délaissé la deuxième partie elle va
parler essentiellement de chocolat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
étaient là mais je reviens réforme en
direct et de vue c'est bien évidemment
touche pas à mon pote